Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Marcus, Priya, Tomás, Naomi, Ben, Sarah, James, Rachel, Kevin, Lily, Mark, Greg. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
Before the main topic, let's do a fast round — where's everyone at? Keep it short.
On my side, the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
I've been heads-down on the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync. It's mostly there; I'll have the next piece up in a couple of days.
On my side, the CARE governance framework is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
Not much to report on community review and the advisory process beyond steady progress. I'll flag it if that changes.
On my side, the backend capability model and the provenance schema is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Right, that's what I meant.
the backend capability model and the provenance schema — steady. One open question I'll raise when we get to it, otherwise fine.
On my side, the access needs-board and credits broker is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Right, that's what I meant.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with community review and the advisory process.
On my side, district partnerships is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
Quick status: district partnerships. On track. I might need a review later but nothing urgent.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Agreed, let's capture it.
Good point — let's do that.
Alright, welcome everybody. This is the kickoff for Aurora Skills. Let me set the frame, because I've been thinking about this a lot. We are building a curated registry of Alaska-related AI skills for classrooms. Two teams.
Platform builds the registry, the manifest format, the review pipeline, and the install experience. Governance and Access handles traditional knowledge, licensing, and the credits program so schools that can't afford to build still get to.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Let's confirm in the channel.
The reason we curate instead of federate is trust. A big open firehose of skills is a security liability and it's a cultural liability. Small, reviewed, regional — that's the whole bet.
I'll be running platform and acting as PM across both for now.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Yeah, exactly.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
That's fair.
Right.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with district partnerships.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Sure, I can own that.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Thanks Dana. I want to add one lens before we divide up. I'll bring a CARE-principles one-pager to every governance session — Collective benefit, Authority to control, Responsibility, Ethics.
It's the language we'll use to decide what belongs in the registry at all.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Good point — let's do that.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Yeah.
Can I ask the question I put in the channel this morning? Whose knowledge is this registry going to hold, and who decided it could be held? I'm not asking rhetorically.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Yeah, exactly.
Before we design a manifest format, do we know who has the authority to say yes?
That tracks.
That's a governance question, and it's exactly why Sarah's team exists in parallel to mine. Platform will build the container; governance decides what's allowed in it.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Let's confirm in the channel.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the backend capability model and the provenance schema anyway.
How does this interact with the CARE governance framework, if at all?
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Good point — let's do that.
Sure, I can own that.
I don't want platform blocked on that though, so we'll design the schema to be permissive and let governance add constraints.
Sorry, can you say that last part again? You cut out for a second.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Sure — one sec.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Okay, works for me.
Sure, I can own that.
Just flagging that this touches the backend capability model and the provenance schema, so loop me in when it firms up.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Good point — let's do that.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Sure, I can own that.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Okay, works for me.
Let's move to the next item.
But isn't that backwards? If the container is built to be permissive and the constraints come later, haven't we already decided the default is yes? Who does a community call if the default let something through?
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the access needs-board and credits broker anyway.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Okay, works for me.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Good point — let's do that.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to community review and the advisory process anyway.
Okay, yeah.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Makes sense to me.
Right, that's what I meant.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with community review and the advisory process.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Agreed, let's capture it.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the backend capability model and the provenance schema.
Sure, I can own that.
James has a point that affects my work directly. If governance rules arrive after the schema is frozen, I have to retrofit them, and retrofits leak. I'd rather the schema start restrictive.
Mm-hm.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Okay, noted, we can start restrictive on capabilities. Let me keep us moving though — I want to talk milestones.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Makes sense to me.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Yeah, exactly.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
That's fair.
Sure, I can own that.
Alpha registry by end of April, review pipeline mid-May, access program design in parallel, and a working demo by end of quarter.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Rachel, you've got the credits program; Tomás, you own security review; Priya, front end; Naomi, backend and the manifest schema; Ben, you're pairing with Naomi.
Governance, Sarah quarterbacks with James on community, Lily on the data model, Mark on licensing, Kevin on partnerships.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Yeah, exactly.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Okay, works for me.
How does this interact with the backend capability model and the provenance schema, if at all?
Wait — before you move on, can you go back one slide?
Sure — one sec.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the CARE governance framework.
That's fair.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Yeah, exactly.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
On the credits program — that came out of Kevin's idea in the channel. I want to name that so the origin's clear. I'll own it.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
That's fair.
Mm-hm.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the CARE governance framework.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Alright, moving on.
Happy for it to be yours. It was a walk-home thought, you're going to make it real.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync.
Agreed, let's capture it.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Great. I think that's the frame. I'll send notes. Let's build.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Hmm, okay.
How does this interact with the backend capability model and the provenance schema, if at all?
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Right, that's what I meant.
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
Quick clarifier — who owns the follow-up here, and by when?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
One thing: how does this affect the the CARE governance framework timeline?
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Dana has the follow-up on the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Sarah has the follow-up on the CARE governance framework — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
James has the follow-up on community review and the advisory process — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.